[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je crois moi l'avoir toujours entendu
dire qu'il voulait pas se présenter
reste un militaire et qu'il n'avait pas
vocation à voir ce poste politique
maintenant avoir un militaire ça c'est
abusé jusqu'à présent on a toujours agi
au sein de coalitions dans des gestions
de crise le kosovo le mali la syrie
l'irak et où on n'a jamais été confronté
de la haute intensité qui est par
exemple face entre guillemets à
l'éventuelle chinois russes et les tv
dans qu'aujourd'hui nous nous préparons
et d'ailleurs c'est un des objectifs du
chef d'état-major des armées terre de
préparer bien son armée terre du combat
haute intensité et a retrouvé certaines
capacités aujourd'hui qu'on en fait un
peu perdu à travers les restrictions
budgétaires
écoutez moi je l' ai connu en tant que
capitaine j'ai encadré et 250 jeunes qui
venaient faire leur service
aujourd'hui vous avions se tournent plus
vers un service civique utiliser les
jeunes dans une vision globale
maintenant le militaire peu près bien
contribué à ce nouveau service militaire
[Musique]
ou le meilleur alors le meilleur de quoi
en tant que goût autant qu'à pression on
est tous parce que moi j'ai fait le les
guerres du golfe ou un j'ai fait le
tchad le kosovo protéger les forces de
l'onu là on vit des moments intenses et
le moins bon ou le souvenir un peu
délicat c'est qu'on peut être je me suis
et j'étais comme mon avion était en
panne sur mirage f1 ou là je me suis
rendu compte que grâce à mon siège
éjectable et je suis encore en vie mais
c'est un moment entre guillemets un peu
délicat oui parce que quand on vieillit
on a beaucoup besoin de reconnaissance
quand on a donné sa vie 36 ans et tout
c'est comme les médailles c'est quand on
est jeune recevoir une médaille
bon on va prend toujours plaisir mais
quand on prend un peu d'âge et quand on
prend un peu de recul sur les choses
on est quand même là pour servir un
militaire est là pour servir et à
l'arrière jusqu'à donner sa vie pour le
pays et donc que quelqu'un vous disais
quand il est assez haut placées que
votre vie vous l'avez bien remplié vous
avez bien servi c'est quelque chose qui
est assez valeurs énormes et j'imagine
que pour le patron d'entreprise ou pour
l'ouvrier pour faire dire à toutes les
classes
on a besoin à un moment ou un autre de
vous dire vous avez bien
[Musique]
chacha